may layla is somebody that kanshu has
his eye on uh i think much to mark
chagrin especially but it does feel like
there's a lot of potential for her as a
character and i'm curious for you would
you ever be interested in kind of taking
up more of a superhero mantle or
becoming someone in the mcu that has a
little bit more of a superpower
uh when i signed on to this i was like
man i always wanted to be a superhero
but it's okay like i'm gonna i'm i'm
happy to represent an egyptian woman in
this world and then the more i
discovered the character i was like well
she she really does feel
like a superhero to me like just just
what you know what she's what i've been
able to play with her like this this
woman who has flaws who's vulnerable but
who can fight
um
i think she's happy where she is
i mean look if something's
in the future whatever but yeah okay
oscar
no um i just want to ask i'm curious
about the what went into creating the
the differences in the physical
performance between stephen and mark we
get a great kind of in-camera moment
where we see the shift take place
and it kind of reminds me a little bit
of like the classic superman scene from
christopher reeve where he takes the
glasses off and his posture just
completely changes it's kind of
emblematic of that
so i'm wondering how you developed those
distinct physical aspects between them
and your performance
yeah i think the first thing thank you
for that yeah that's an amazing moment
you know and and
and the truth is
really like what makes superman
interesting is clark kent you know
superman without clark kent is just kind
of like all right yeah whatever but you
know the it's it's that dichotomy
between the two things which i think is
what speaks to people so much and so
that's why it was really fun
finding this character of stephen um
and then being able to lean into maybe
some of the more traditional ideas of
what you know the vigilante dark
brooding guy is because he's got this
little guy that lives inside of this
little englishman um and so finding
the way that he expresses himself steven
someone that is desperate for connection
but doesn't have the skills to do it
um you know he i saw him as a bit on the
spectrum i actually loved i loved
watching love on the spectrum that was
like one of my favorite things to look
at because i just found it so moving and
touching because it's people that you
know they're all the same feelings we
have in those situations but you know
they just haven't developed all the
masks to hide it all you know and so
there was there was cues that i took
from that
um
i imagined him as quite tall but wanting
to feel smaller you know in when he
walks through rooms and things
um
yeah and just played with the
physicality and then just a very open
face you know which kind of reminded me
of my clown days back at school you know
where you play with the red nose and the
way that it opens up your face
and then doing the opposite of that with
with mark making him although much more
present like a like marble in the middle
of a room but also tighter in the face
and you know um closed off there's lots
lots of defenses up
and then and may and then
you know it took me a while to get to
the place where i felt comfortable
enough
that it wasn't just an external change
but it was an internal change to be able
to shift
and then and that's why i was able
because they were kind enough to help me
out with that when we shot you know like
only shooting stephen at first and only
shooting market first separately and
then slowly as i got more comfortable i
was like all right guys i won't make you
bend over backwards with a schedule we
can do it on the same day and
ultimately we came up with that moment
something that's fabulous about the moon
night costume is that depending on who's
wearing it at the moment it changes so
for both of you i'm curious if you had
to pick
your own moon night costume
what would it look like and why wow i
never
thought about this i would want
pants
like i like
i think it's a solid place to start
yeah
and i think the game's pretty cool
i would go no pants
and cake and the cake it's just the cake
just the cake that's the cake yeah
i feel like that's the perfect place to
wrap on and that's all the time i have
but thank you both so much for taking
the time to talk to me about the show i
can't wait to see how these next couple
episodes pan out for these characters so
thank you thank you
you